the classroom of the future would be
like any other classroom except I think
it'd be very few textbooks people would
have pads or tablets we were long to get
information then you'd raise the
expectation you'd have okay you got the
tablet you have access to all the
information on earth now go find out
something then investigate it hands-on
and then ideally you'd have kids you
have students publish their results for
the world and that happens to an extent
right now I mean science teachers who
are go-getters are always publishing
there there are students results and at
the Planetary Society we're gonna rev up
the earth dial program again so there'll
be a third sundial on Mars in August
August 5th or 6th depending on your time
zone the Curiosity rover will land on
Mars it as the 3rd Mars sundial you can
build a replica or in a ten-time size
model of the same sundial here on earth
and put a camera on it send us the
picture to the Planetary Society website
we will show the Sun dials around the
world and what I'm saying is we're using
the Internet to share information around
the world you're building the sundial
yourself and you are doing this ancient
fundamental astronomy the accuracy that
these people figured out the length of
the Earth's year is astonishing they did
it nope no pictures of the Earth from
space no cell phones accurate to a
couple thousandth of a second a year no
they did it by dint of watching ship I
just carefully watching shadows dint of
careful observation
you